GREG:  IT'S LIKE I'M CRYING BUT
I'M NOT.
TALK ABOUT A VICIOUS CYCLE.
I CALL IT THE TRUMP 360.
TRUMP SAYS OR TWEETS SOMETHING
OUTRAGEOUS, THE MEDIA FREAKS
OUT, FILLING THEIR DEPENDS WITH
COMPOST.
IT'S THE END OF THE WORLD.
I MEAN, JUST LOOK AT THEIR HAIR.
♪
GREG:  THEN A MONTH LATER, THEY
REALIZE, DAMN, THE LOUD, CRAZY
ORANGE GUY HAD A POINT AND THEY
TRY TO FORGET IT EVER HAPPENED.
LOOK AT ISIS, HOW THEY LAUGHED
WHEN TRUMP SAID HE WOULDN'T TELL
THE MEDIA HIS SECRET PLAN.
THEN NOT SPILLING THE BEANS
WORKED.
ISIS WAS LIKE WHOA, THERE GOES
MY LEGS.
DIDN'T SEE THAT COMING.
DON'T WORRY, NEITHER DID CNN.
REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP LECTURED
NATO ALLIES ON DEFENSE SPENDING.
WE LAUGHED.
I LAUGHED.
UNTIL THEY AGREED TO HIS
DEMANDS.
I WAS WRONG.
TRUMP RAILED AGAINST TRADE
IMBALANCES.
THEN WE STARTED LEARNING ABOUT
TRADE IMBALANCES AND NOW WE HAVE
A NEW DEAL.
PEOPLE DRAGGED HIM FOR HIS TWEET
ABOUT THE WILDFIRES.
A WEEK LATER, EXPERTS ADMITTED
MISMANAGEMENT MADE THE FIRES
WORSE.
TRUMP SAID PUERTO RICO WAS
PLAGUED WITH CORRUPTION.
THAT WAS MEAN AND COLD.
THEN CITY COUNCIL OFFICES  WERE
RAIDED BY THE FBI AND HURRICANE
DONATIONS  WERE FOUND ROTTING IN
A PARKING LOT.
REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP SAID ALL
JUDGES HAVE POLITICAL LEANINGS.
CHUCK SCHUMER TWEETED THAT TRUMP
WAS WRONG.
EVEN AS CHUCK THEN LABELED JOHN
ROBERTS A PARTISAN AND A
REPUBLICAN.
WASN'T THAT TRUMP'S POINT, YOU
PREENING HAIR PLUG.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE
RIGHT AND HE WAS WRONG BUT
WHOOPS, I THINK CHRIS SUMS IT UP
BEST.
>> I REMEMBER SOMEONE TEACHING
ME, JIM, WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
KINDS OF DEALS, IT IS WORSE WHEN
IT HAPPENS IN REVERSE, HE USED
TO SAY TO ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  SOMETHING'S WRONG WITH
THAT MAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  THERE'S THE TREND, THE
PERIOD BETWEEN A TRUMP TWEET AND
THAT REALIZATION THAT IT MIGHT
BE CORRECT, IT KEEPS GETTING
SMALLER AS SMALL AS A CHIPMUM'S
UNDERPANTS IT'S NOT TRUMP'S
CRITICS HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
TRUTH N. HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
TRUMP SAYING IT.
THAT'S WHAT OUTRAGES THE MEDIA
MOST.
EVEN WITH TRUMP'S SLOPPINESS,
HE'S OFTEN RIGHT.
HE'S A CROSS BETWEEN EINSTEIN
AND A DRUNK.
I MEAN --
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  I,
IEG:  I,
I.G:  I,
GREG:  I MEAN, WHO HERE DOESN'T
LIKE THEIR CHILDREN?
>> WHO HERE DOES NOT LIKE THEIR
CHILDREN?
THERE'S NOBODY?
GOT TO BE SOMEBODY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T LIKE THEIR
CHILDREN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  HE'S NOT LYING.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HATE
THEIR KIDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  I HATE MY KIDS AND I
DON'T EVEN HAVE ANY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  NOW, TAKE THE CARAVAN.
WHO KEPT WARNING EVERYONE THIS
WAS NOT GOING TO END WELL?
>> WE ARE SENDING A SIMPLE
MESSAGE TO THE LAWLESS CARAVANS
AND THE ILLEGAL TRESPASSERS
MARCHING TOWARD OUR BORDER.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
TURN BACK NOW, GO BACK HOME, WE
WILL NOT LET YOU IN.
GREG:  HOW DID THE MEDIA REACT
IN THEY CALLED THE CARAVAN A
MAKE BELIEVE RIGHT WING DREAM.
>> THIS IDEA UNFOUNDED OF AN
INVASION OF IMMIGRANTS --
>> THE PRESIDENT FALSELY
DESCRIBED THE CARAVAN AS AN
INVASION.
>> FOR EVERYBODY OUT THERE THAT
WAS TELLING ME KNOW, IT'S A REAL
STORY, WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
CARAVAN, THEY'RE COMING, I GO
BACK TO WHAT I SAID ABOUT
MARTIANS COMING TO MY BACKYARD.
THEY'RE NOT COMING.
GREG:  BOY, DOES HE LOOK STUPID.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  MORE SO THAN USUAL.
THAT'S QUITE AN ACHIEVEMENT.
BECAUSE HE'S KIND OF STUPID
EVERY DAY.
AS FOR THE HORROR OVER PEPPER
SPRAY, THE MEDIA MISSED ALL THE
TIMES THE BORDER PATROL
DISPENSED TEAR GAS UNDER OBAMA.
IF OBAMA DID IT THEY'D CALL IT
DISBURSEMENT DRIZZLE.
I BET TRUMP USED THE STUFF LESS.
WHEN TRUMP P SAYS DON'T COME,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SPRAY ANYONE.
THE MEDIA IS OUTRAGED THEY
HAPPENED TO BE RIGHT.
THE CARAVAN ARRIVED AND THEY
WERE ASSAULTED, JUST DOING THEIR
JOBS.
THE MAYOR OF TIJUANA IS PISSED
ABOUT THE CARAVAN AND HE'S THE
MAYOR OF TIJUANA.
ALMOST ANYTHING GOES THERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  I BURNED ALL OF THAT
FILM, I THINK, A LONG TIME AGO,
BACK WHEN YOU COULD BURN FILM.
TELL ME AGAIN WHO ARE THE BAD
GUYS IN THIS EQUATION?
A MOB THROWS BOTTLES AND HITS
US.
WHEN WE RESPOND, WE GET BLAMED.
IT FEELS LIKE A SETUP EGGED ON
BY A MEDIA DROOLING FOR A PHOTO.
THE PEOPLE TALKING COMPASSION
MAY CARE LESS THAN THE WHITE
HOUSE TRYING TO MAINTAIN ORDER.
TRUMP SAID IT WOULDN'T END WELL,
AND THEY LAUGHED.
WHEN IT DIDN'T END WELL, THEY
BLAMED.
IF THEY COULD LISTEN TO HIM
WITHOUT SEEING HIM, THEY WOULD
PROBABLY FEEL DIFFERENTLY.
>> WE'RE NOT LETTING PEOPLE INTO
OUR COUNTRY UNLESS THEY COME IN
LEGALLY.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO COME IN
THROUGH MERIT.
>> I CAN'T STAND THIS GUY.
HE SAYS TERRIBLE THINGS.
NONE OF WHICH ARE CORRECT, BY
THE WAY.
>> ABOUT THE IMMIGRANTS, OBAMA
MADE THE SAME POINT IN 2005.
>> REALLY?
IT SOUNDS SO MUCH WORSE COMING
FROM HIM.
>> HAVING TROUBLE ADMITTING
TRUMP'S RIGHT SOMETIMES?
>> YES, I AM, EVEN WHEN HE HAS
POINT.
I HATE IT WHEN HE SAYS IT.
>> SOUNDS LIKE YOU NEED TRUMP
BLOCKERS.
>> WHAT ARE THOSE?
>> TRUMP BLOCKERS ARE THE
HOTTEST THING THAT MAKES YOU
THINK A POLITICIAN YOU LIKE SAYS
SOMETHING INSTEAD OF TRUMP.
YOU WILL INSTANTLY HEAR THE
TRUMP FROM WHO YOU WANT TO HEAR
FROM.
>> I BUILT A GREAT COMPANY.
YOU DON'T BUILD COMPANIES LIKE
THAT UNLESS HAVE YOU THE RIGHT
TEMPER MEANT.
REPUBLICANNING WANT TO --
REPUBLICANS WANT TO PROTECT
MEDICARE FOR THE SENIORS WHO ARE
EARNED IT AND PAID FOR IT ALL
THEIR LIVES.
>> WOW, THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> WOMEN'S UNEMPLOYMENT HAS JUST
FALLEN TO 3.6% WHICH IS ONLY THE
LOWEST RATE IN 65 YEARS.
I'M SORRY.
>> WOW, THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> THE ELITE, THE ELITE, WHY ARE
THEY ELITE?
I HAVE A MUCH BETTER APARTMENT
THAN THEY DO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M SMARTER THAN THEY ARE.
I'M RICHER THAN THEY ARE.
>> HOW DOES OBAMA COME UP WITH
THIS STUFF?
>> GET YOUR TRUMP BLOCKERS
TODAY.
>> I LOVE MY TRUMP BLOCKERS.
EVEN WHEN I'M NOT WEARING THEM,
THERE'S ONE SIDE EFFECT.
YOU HEY, JIMMY, HOW WAS YOUR
WEEKEND?
>> THE END OF THE WEEK I MEET
WITH CHINA, I MEET WITH A LOT OF
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT HAVE NOT
TREATED US TOO WELL BUT WE'RE
DOING EXTREMELY WELL.
>> SEE WHAT I MEAN?
HEY, CAT, LOOKING GOOD.
>> OTHER THAN THE BLONDE HAIR
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP, THEY SAID
I LOOK LIKE ELVIS.
DO YOU SEE THAT?
>> TOTALLY.
THANKS DONALD
THANKS TONALD
THANKS TRUALD
THANKS TRUMPD
THANKS TRUMP BLOCKERS.
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
GREG:  ALL RIGHT.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
HIS TATTOO'S COULD BEAT YOUR
YOUR TATTOO'S.
MASTER SERGEANT TERRY SHEPHERD.
GREG:  HE'S A
GREG:  HE'S MOLE WITH NO SOUL,
FORMER CIA OPERATIVE, MIKE
BAKER.
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
GREG:  HER GLASSES ARE AS THICK
AS MOLASSES, CAT TIPP.
AND EVERY STEP HE TAKES CREATES
A NEW POOL FOR THE KIDS, FORMER
WWE SUPERSTAR, MASSIVE SIDE
KICK, TYRUS.
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THAT WAS FANTASTIC.
GREG:  I THINK THAT'S THE
SOLUTION.
YOU TAKE EVERYTHING TRUMP SAYS
AND FILTER IT THROUGH THE BODY
OF OBAMA AND YOU GET -- HAVE YOU
THE PERFECT THING.
>> YOU JUST SOLVED EVERYTHING IN
THE COUNTRY RIGHT THERE.
GREG:  I LIKE TO DO THAT.
I COULD SOLVE ALSO YOUR SHOE
CHOICES.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
GREG:  IT'S INTERESTING.
>> WHERE DID YOU GET THESE FROM?
OFF OF JAMES BROWN.
>> THEY SAY NOTHING BACK STAGE
AND THEY COME OUT HERE AND GIVE
ME A BUNCH OF -- BY THE WAY,
WELL DONE.
GREG:  THANK YOU.
>> REMEMBER THAT MOVIE, STOP
TOUCHING ME.
THEY LIVE.
GREG:  THAT WAS THE IDEA.
I STOLE IT FROM "THEY LIVE."
>> ONE OF MY FAVORITE SCI-FI
MOVIES, IT'S WORTH SEEING IT.
HE PUTS ON GLASSES AND THEN HE
SEES BASICALLY ALL THE AUTHORITY
FIGURES ARE ALIENS RUNNING THE
SHOW AND THERE'S SUBLIMINAL
MESSAGES AND HE FIGURES IT OUT.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO
TRUMP FOR THIS, WHETHER YOU LIKE
HIM OR HATE HIM.
HE'S GOTTEN US TALKING ABOUT --
WHO KNEW ANYTHING ABOUT -- I DO,
BECAUSE I'M SMART AND I'M A
SPECIAL FORCES GUY BUT WHO KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT NATO OR NAFTA.
REMEMBER, TRUMP LOOKS AT AMERICA
AS THE NEW TRUMP CORPORATION.
I'M SERIOUS.
GREG:  YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> HE'S SITTING THERE GOING
BUDDY, WHAT IS THIS NATO THING,
WE'RE DOING THIS, NOT GETTING
THIS, NO, NO, NO, FIX THAT.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S ALWAYS THE
BEST WAY TO GO BUT IT'S WORKING.
HE'S LOOKING AT EVERYTHING WITH
A HARD LINE, GOING I KNOW IT'S
BEEN 30 YEARS, WE'RE GETTING
SCREWED ON THIS.
GREG:  IT'S LIKE HE'S LIKE A GUY
THAT TAKES OVER A BUSINESS AND
ASKS REALLY DUMB QUESTIONS THAT
NO ONE ELSE WILL ASK, LIKE CAN
WE GET RID OF THIS OR CAN WE DO
THAT, I DON'T KNOW, AND THEN YOU
END UP WITH A NATIONAL POLYSCI
CLASS.
I DON'T KNOW CRAP ABOUT NATO, I
DON'T KNOW CRAP ABOUT TRADE.
>> NOW YOU DO G I WAS
>> NOW YOU DO.G I WAS
GREG:  I WAS FORCED TO.
BECAUSE TRUMP ASKS DUMB
QUESTIONS, THE QUESTIONS GO IN A
CERTAIN PATH THAT LEAD TO
INTERESTING ANSWERS.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
ANYBODY WAS INTERESTED IN
WATCHING THE G-20 SUMMIT, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  WE CAN'T SHOW THE
AUDIENCE, MIKE.
>> ONE PERSON RAISED THEIR HAND.
>> ANYBODY OVER HERE ON THIS
SIDE?
>> SO YOU'RE RIGHT, IT'S LIKE IN
THE OLD SCHOOL DAYS, RIGHT, WHEN
NOBODY WANTED TO ASK THE
QUESTION.
WHEN YOU FINALLY GOT THAT ONE
KID WHO JUST I DON'T GET IT, HE
WOULD ASK THE QUESTION,
EVERYBODY WAS LIKE THANK GOD HE
SAID THAT.
NOBODY KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
THAT'S THE STUFF THAT GETS
FIXED.
GREG:  YOU KNOW WHAT, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THIS FOR THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS OR THE NEXT TWO MORE
YEARS MANY PEOPLE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT WHEN IS THE RESISTANCE
GOING AWAY, WHEN ARE THEY GOING
TO WIND THIS DOWN.
THEY'RE NOT IS THE ANSWER.
JUST LIKE THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS NOT GOING AWAY.
IT WILL KEEP TICKING ALONG.
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT THIS,
BECAUSE IT'S THE WORLD WE LIVE
IN.
>> IT IS THE WORLD WE LIVE IN.
THAT'S ONE OF THE STATEMENTS YOU
CAN SAY TO WRAP THINGS.
GREG:  WE'RE ALWAYS HAPPY WHEN
MIKE DOES WRAP THINGS UP.
HE TENDS TO RAMBLE AND 80 TO 90%
OF WHAT HE SAYS WE DON'T KNOW.
>> I DON'T DO MY RESEARCH.
CARLEY:
.ARLEY:
.GRLEY:
.GREGY:
.GREG:  CAT, YOU ALWAYS DO YOUR
RESEARCH.
THIS IS WHY TRUMP KEPT ASKING IF
HE COULD FIRE PEOPLE.
HE WAS LIKE COULD I FIRE THE
POLICE.
HE DOESN'T -- HE SOMEHOW
STUMBLES TO AN ANSWER AND HE
ENDS UP BEING RIGHT.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HE
DOES, PEOPLE WHO ARE LIBERAL
WILL HATE HIM BECAUSE THE
ELECTION BROKE THEIR HEARTS.
THE WAY THEY FEEL ABOUT TRUMP IS
THE WAY I FEEL ABOUT MY
EX-BOYFRIEND.
GREG:  OF COURSE.
>> NO MATTER WHAT HE DOES, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
MY EX-BOYFRIEND COULD INVENT A
CURE FOR THE COMMON COLD, AND
WOULD I GET HIM CREDIT FOR HIM?
I WOULD CREATE A CULT THAT
TEACHES THAT SNEEZING AND
COUGHING ARE THE WAY INTO
HEAVEN.
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
>> IT'S WEIRD THEY'RE SO
EMOTIONALLY AFFECTED.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THE GUY.
IT CONTROLS ALL THEIR EMOTIONS.
IT'S QUITE SAD.
GREG:  I THINK IN A WAY WE ALL
KNOW TRUMP BECAUSE WE HAVE
SOMEONE LIKE HIM IN OUR LIVES.
I ALWAYS CALL HIM THE RICH
OBNOXIOUS UNCLE WHO KNOWS
EVERYTHING.
WHEN HE COMES OVER, I THINK I'M
THAT GUY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  I GO SIT IN THE GARAGE
AND GET DRUNK BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT I DO.
>> SURE.
ABSOLUTELY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'VE SEEN HIM DO IT.
HE GETS DRUNK IN THE GARAGE ALL
THE TIME.
GREAT, NOW LET'S GO TO
COMMERCIAL.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION?
>>
.>
.GREG:  NO, I ASSUMED IN YOUR
MIND YOU HAVE A WAY TO WRAP THIS
ALL TOGETHER.
>> I'M VERY PROUD OF YOU THAT
YOU SOLVED THE DIVISION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
GREG:  YES.
>> BARACK OBAMA AND --
GREG:  TRUMP.
>> TRUMP'S VOICE.
THEY CHEERED FOR BARACK OBAMA.
THIS WORKS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREG:  THE AUDIENCE CHEERED.
>> TWO THINGS YOU CAN COUNT ON
ON THIS SHOW, YOU BEING WEIRD
AND YOU SAYING OBAMA OR YOU SAY
HILLARY, YOU'RE GOING TO GET
BOOS.
EVEN IF YOU TOOK HILLARY WITH
TRUMP'S VOICE, YOU WOULD STILL
GET A COUPLE OH, NO, I DON'T
KNOW.
SO IT'S AN AMAZING MOMENT.
GREG:  YES.
>> I'M GLAD -- THIS IS LIKE
WATCHING SOMEBODY WALK ON THE
MOON FOR THE FIRST TIME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT'S A GOOD STEP FORWARD.
>> WE COULD WALK INTO THE NEXT
TOWN HALL, PEOPLE YELLING AT
EACH OTHER, I'LL SET UP THE
PROJECTOR, WATCH THIS, Y'ALL.
GREG:  I THINK I COULD RETIRE
NOW.
I'M GOING TO LEAVE.
SEE YOU GUYS LATER.